tu peux nous faire quoi mon camion je
sais pas je voulais faire l'essai de
nous faire énormément me begeot
mimolette quand j'ai froid se fait
lumière j'aime aller ce fait pris hier à
midi tout dans un silence
je souffre elle souffre avec moi quand
je ris elle rit aux éclats avec mon
public
mes chansons sont souvent pour elle elle
sera toujours ma merveille
quand je ne sais pas mm
plus haut
la scène
ce sens sont venus à l'appel
fois la guerre des mots clés
oh
ce n'est pas
elle repense encore chasse le vent elle
ment pas les mêmes
m
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas ce que ça
non même il est mince mais m
m
pas nous
ça
j'adore quand il fait ça je comprends
jamais ce qui me croient je dis des
conneries c'est moi joe biden ça fait
déjà plus d'une semaine je n'ai plus de
tes nouvelles
oui ça chante comme ça gars sympa monk
angie si vous voulez faire les deux -
petit rose à brossard où ça si tu es
venu pour me parler sur ce ton je
préfère que tu me dis tout de suite je
suis pas ton couteau vois tu vois un
gradient qui n est pas c'est quoi le
premier complexe
c
mama si tu as magenta
c'est
ça
oh
l arrêt
sam
ça
[Musique]